อา
กูเอสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูต้องสวัสดีนัก
เรียนทุกคนด้วยนะคะนักเรียนแล้วพูดอุ้ย
คู๋ผมผมยุ่งนะคะวันนี้หวีผมหรือยังเดี๋ยว
ครูเอกแว่นสัตว์ออกใครอ่ะกูอ่ะผมยุ่งนิด
หน่อยอ่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้วันอะไรครับกูต้อง
วันนี้นะครับวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันนี้
วันอาทิตย์นะคะ
[เพลง]
วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8 ค่า
กูเอ๋วันที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนพฤษภาคม
ค่ะเดือนพฤษภาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ
2000  22 ค่ะ 2022 ตอนนี้เวลาออกกี่โมง
คะคุณต้องตอนนี้เวลา
9:00 น 8 นาทีแล้วค่ะ 3 ทุ่ม 8 นาทีกู
ต้องยังไม่นอนใช่ไหมค่ะยังไม่นอนค่ะต้อง
ทำงานกับครูเอ๋ก่อนนะคะทำงานกับคู่เอก
ก่อนถึงจะไปนอนได้ค่ะอาเดี๋ยวเราจะพูดกัน
จนถึง 21:00 น 3  10 น 48 นะคะโอเคค่ะ
ทุ่ง
ครึ่งชั่วโมงให้ 5 ชั่วโมง 30 นาทีไม่ใช่
30 ชั่วโมง
3  30 นาที 5
30 นาทีนะคะคุณต้องมีค่านะคะโอเคกู n ลบ
นะคะคุณต้อมรถเลยค่ะไปรบก่อนนะต้องหลบไป
ก่อน
โอเคลบค่ะอันนี้ลบๆนะคะอาอ้าอ้าวโอเค
โอเคกูเองค่ะเนี้ยที่ครูต้อมพูดถามถึงคู๋
ผมยุ่งอ่ะทำไมอ้ะผมยุ่งมั้ง
กูต้อมจะถามกูเองว่าไปร้านทำผมบ้างหรือ
เปล่าอ๋อ
ร้านทำผมหรอถ้าร้านทำผมก็เราก็ต้องอาบมี
ร้านใช่ไหมร้านยังไงถ้า
ร้านแบบนี้
แล้วก็ข้างในก็จะมีอะไรไม่รู้ข้างในก็จะ
มี
มินี่แล้วอีที่กำลังที่นี่หรือบางทีตรง
นี้นี่มีกระจกหน้าโจกระจกกระจกเม้นท์มี
กระจกตรงเนี้ยอ่ะแล้วเราก็มีเก้าอี้รัก
กันน่ะพรุ่งนี้หนูก็นั่งแล้วก็มีมีถ้าถ้า
มีช่างทำผม
ได้เอออันนี้กูเองไม่ได้ไปค่ะเพื่อนปรับ
ให้
โอ๊ยอ่า
คู๋ผมยาวจนถึงวันอาทิตย์ที่แล้ว
โอ๊ยอาทิตย์ที่แล้วผมยังยาวแล้วก็มี
เพื่อนเพื่อนครูเอ๋เรื่อง kuai เป็นช่าง
ทำผม
เพื่อนเรียนทำผมอยู่ชื่อ
อะเรียนตัดผมแล้วก็กูเองครับผมเนี่ย
ยาว
ก็เลยบอกตัดผมให้หน่อย
ผมจริงๆจะให้ฟันแบบนี้ค่ะเลยแต่ติมอร์โอ๋
อันนี้เพื่อนตัดภัยแต่ว่าถ้าไม่มีใดหนอ
ค่าคู๋หน้าอะอันนี้ใดใช่ไหมคะค่ะเหมือน
ไหมในมีสายอ่ะมีสายไฟ
ที่ผมสั้นเสร็จแล้วมันต้องใดใช่ไหมคะครู
เอมให้แล้วก็เอกก็ไม่ไปไม่ไปร้านทำผมทำผม
5 ปีแล้วโอ้โห
ครูต้องมาค่ะชอบไอน้ำทำผมแต่ไม่มีเวลาไป
ร้านทำผมเพราะว่าทำไมคุณกันไปร้านทำผม
เวลาไปร้านทำผมด้วยนะคะเหมือนสบายมากเวลา
ที่เรานอนแล้วช่างทำผมอ่ะเขาก็จะสระผม
เล่าๆนวดนวดนวด
นี้บายมากเลยค่ะพี่เอ๋หวานให้อ่ะเอาออกมี
คุณตั้มต้องขึ้นไปที่ไหนนะไปไปร้านที่ผม
ได้ไปนิดเตียงใช่ไหมคะให้ค่ะมีเตียงนอน
เตียงนอน
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะใช่ๆเป็นเปียง่ายต้องถามว่า
ใช่ไหมเพราะกูเองไม่ได้ไป
บางทีก็เป็นเปียบางทีก็เป็นแบบเหมือนเรา
อี้
ผสมเตียงเหงื่อ
ema มาค่ะเก้าอี้สระผมกูเองแล้วก็ตรงนี้
ก็จะเป็น
เป็นซิงค์แอบเป็นอาจ
เป็นอ่างสำหรับสระผม
อาจ
ได้ค่ะพรุ่งนี้ก็จะมีอะไรนะนี่
ก๊อกน้ำ
ต้มสุกต้องสีน้ำตาลแล้วกันเนาะคุณต้อมก็
อยู่ที่นี่ค่ะอ่ะ
อยู่
ตรงนี้นะคะแล้วก็นอน
ที่นี่
ครับผมสีดำ
น
แล้วงอนไปเลย
เรายังไงคะเขามีแชมพูมีผู้หญิงมีผู้หญิง
เป็นช่างทำผมเป็นวิกหวีหญิงผู้หญิงนะคะ
พี่หญิงค่ะ
และ
สระผมเราก็จะมาสระผมให้สะอาดนะคะเอาน้ำนะ
กูต้องต้องบอกก่อนนะเวลาเดินไปที่ร้านทำ
ผมเขาจะถามอะไรคุณต้องค่ะเขาถามว่าทำอะไร
คะวันนี้มาทำอะไรคะ
กูเอกจ่ายน้ำสวัสดีค่ะคุณต้องวันนี้มาทำ
อะไรคะวันนี้มาสระผมอย่างเดียวค่ะมาสิ่ง
ใดด้วยไหมคะได้ด้วยค่ะสระไดร์นะคะค่ะไดร์
ค่ะสระผมไดร์ผมอาหารและคุณต้องต้องบอก
อะไรเขาอีกนะคะเวลาสับ
ไม่ต้องบอกอะไรแล้วค่ะแต่บางครั้งครูต้อม
ก็บอกเขาว่า
ผมเบาเบาๆไม่ต้องเก่าๆแรงๆ
ไม่เอาใช่ไหมเอาไม่เอาเจอเจ็บเอาอันเนี้ย
เก่านักเรียนเนี้ยมีเล็บให้เห็นเล็บไหมคะ
เล็บคู๋เล็บยาวมากเลยอ่ะเว็บเกาะเก่า
การอมเอาเกาหัวใช่ไหมเอาหัวนวดไหมคะไม่
งวดค่ะ
ใช้มือนวด
ไม่ใช่เล็บล่ะคะแต่ใช้ตรงนี้แล้วก็นวด
หมอนวดชายค่ะ
หนูงวดอ๋อไม่ไม่เอาไปแต่เอานวดนะคะเราเอา
นวดงั้นกูตั้มต้องบอกเขาว่ายังไงนะเอาอีก
1 รอบอ่ะ
ไม่กล้าเอา
รู้วันเบาเบาๆนะคะนวลก็เบาๆชายเก่าไม่เอา
เอาไม่เอาด้วยตอบเบาๆ
ก็บอกแบบนี้จะสบายมากไม่เจ็บค่ะอ๊อดศนวด
เบาๆนะคะแล้วอ่ะใด
ได้ปกติ
แล้วเอาใดไม่ต้องบอกไม่ต้องบอกว่าไม่เอา
ร้อนไม่ต้องบอกค่ะได้ปกติเลยร้อนหรือบาง
ทีเขาใดเขาดึงอย่างเงี้ย
อุ้ยแล้วจึงโมงก็เมื่อก่อนไม่ก่อนกูเอก
เลยนะอ้ำผมเราก็มีคนนี้ก็เดินกันนี้คนนี้
ก็ดึงดึงอู้ 2 คนเดินนึงครูเอนเหนื่อยมาก
อุ้ยก็เกือบบ้างไม่ไปร้านทำผมโอ๊ยแล้วผม
คู๋ไม่หลุดออกมาเลยหรอคะผมทำไอ้หลุดคอน่า
จะหลุด
ลุ่ยโหมดหลายมาก
นะกลัวว่ารักช่างทำผมผู้หญิงนะ
ถ้าช่างทำผมเป็นผู้ชายถ้าผู้ชายหรือว่า
ผู้หญิงผมสั้นแล้วสวัสดีฮะอันนี้อกน้อ
หน้า
หนาวไม่ชอบช่างผู้หญิงมาน้อหมอช่างนี้ชาย
กระบัตรคอยมือบ้าน
ผู้หญิงมากสารคู๋เลยใช่ก็เลยทำไมกูเองไม่
ไปร้านทำผมและคุณเอ๋ถามกูต้องเนี่ยมีอะไร
ต้องบอกอีกไหม
เห้อกูเองไม่ไปเลยกูต้องมาชอบไปหาว่าเวลา
ไปร้านทำผมก็ต้องบอกเขาว่าไม่กาวแรงๆให้
หนูนวดเบาเบาๆไม่เนี้ยค่ะใดเบาๆต้องบอก
ไหมไม่ต้องบอกเพราะกูต้องไม่ผมยาวผมผมแค่
นี้ผมไม่ยาวมากนี่ครูเอ๋มาก่อนผมยาวแล้ว
ก็ปกหูเหนอ่ะเยอะอ๋อ
ผมหนาวเวลาใดก็ต้องดื้อ
เยอะอ่ะแต่ผมค้าเยอะมาก
ถ้าอะไรต้องดึงเยอะๆดึงๆช่างทำผมว่าคุณ
ต้องเขาไม่ชอบผมเอ๋ทำไมอ้ะผมมันเยอะแล้ว
ผมมันยาว
เขาไม่ชอบแต่ว่าถ้าไม่ร้านที่เป็นผู้ชาย
เขาโอเค 5 หน้าร้านที่เป็นผู้ชายเขาจะบอก
ว่าอุ้ยผมยาวผมเยอะดีมากคุ้มสวย
[เพลง]
ผู้ยังแล้วก็
มีอีกหนึ่งคนค่ะเป็นลูกชายของครูต้อมค่ะ
ชอบไปร้านตัดผมก็ขอเหมือนกันกับผู้ชายไป
เดี๋ยวกูต้อมน่ะเดี๋ยวนะคุณต้องไปร้าน
ไดร์สระผมเนี่ยหา
บ่อยไหมคะ good
คือเวลานฝากผม
2 เดือน 1 ครั้งขอ 2 เดือนนะ 2 เดือน
เพราะคุณต้อมไม่ได้ออกจากบ้านเลยกลัวโคย
อ๋อหนึ่งครั้งนะคะลูกชายครูต้อมไปร้านตัด
ผมเนี่ย
1 ครั้งเดือนละ 1 ครั้งค่ะ 1 เดือน
1 คันหางปล่อยเนาะให้ค่ะเพราะว่าเขาผม
สั้นผมสั้นมากๆต้องตัดผมทุกเดือนผู้ชาย
ต้องตัดผมทุกเดือนๆค่ะเหมือนสามีครูเอกก็
1 เดือน 1 ครั้งตัดผมตัดอีกแล้วอาจอีกที
สัตว์อีกแล้วนะเขาบอกว่าร้อนยังคานผมเยอะ
เนี่ยเมื่อๆแล้วมันจะเบา OK
มาแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะคุณต้องชอบไปนวดแล้ว
ก็ไม่ต้องบอกอะไรไม่ต้องบอกว่าเพราะว่า
เอ๋ได้เคยได้ยินน้ำบางคนบอกว่าเอาใดเย็นๆ
ไม่ร้อนนี่เหมือนกันพอใดจะร้อนมากใช่ค่ะ
และลูกชายกูต้องไปตัดผมทุกเดือนในช่วงปิด
เนี่ยตัดได้ค่ะร้านตัดทุ่งโควิชร้านตัดผม
ปิดปิดสนิทเลยไม่เปิดเลย 6 เดือน 7 เดือน
8 เดือนไม่เปิดเลยค่ะอ่ะกูต้อมต้องเป็น
ช่างทำผมเองฮะกูต้องตัดผมให้ลูกเหรอคะ
ต้อมต้องเอาเนี้ยค่ะเอากรรไกรมาค่ะแล้วก็
ตัดๆๆๆ
ผมให้ลูกเองค่ะอันนั้นกรรไกรเดี๋ยวขอดู
กรรไกรอ่ะ
กูต้องอันนั้นกันกันอัดกระดาษนะอันนั้น
กระไดค่ะอ๊ะป่าวไม่มีจำใจตัดผมไม่มีใช้
กรรไกรตัดกระดาษอันนี้หน้าตัดผมได้
ใช้กูต้องใช้อันนี้เลยค่ะ
กูต้องตัดคุณต้องไปใดโศกค่ะ
กรรไกรสำหรับตัดผมใช่ไหมคะได้ V ค่ะมี
ต้องวันเคค่ะจะคุยกับข้าวไปได้จ้ะ
ไม่แพงไว้แทงโอเคโอเคทีนี้ครูต้องตัดให้
นานและ 6 เดือนแล้วผมลูกชายก็ยาวพอเดี๋ยว
รถตรงนี้ก่อนนะคะ
กี่เดือนนะ
6 เดือนแล้วค่ะอ๋อ
เดี๋ยวหมายความว่า
ตัดทุกเดือนหรือว่าตัด 6 เดือนที่แล้วอาจ
6 เดือนที่แล้วค่ะอร์ด 6 เดือนที่แล้วก็
เดือนอะไรคะอ้า
ว่ากันว่าเห้ยเดือนเดือนพฤษภาคมธันวาคม of
November
พฤศจิกา 2021 ค่ะอันนี้ลูกชายมะลิสามีคุณ
ต้อมคุณต้อมไม่ใช่ลูกชายครูต้อมแนบ
ตัดผม
ลูกชายให้ค่ะจะไปวัดให้ไหมอ่ะคุณต้อมซุป
อุ่นทำที่นี่ล่ะค่ะ
แล้วก็มีกรรไกร
กันไก่
กันไก่ใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ฝากไงตาย
ตอนเดือน
เดือนนี้ใช่ไหมคะให้ค่ะตอนนี้เดือนถึง of
1 ครั้งนะคะตัด 1 ให้ค่าทอดถึงเดือนเสือ
เดือนไงค่ะ
สภาคมตรงนี้ก็คือ 6  6 เดือน 6 เดือนที่
แล้วตัดผมตายอย่างก็บอกลูกชายต้องตัดผม
ทุกเดือนเดือนค่ะเดือนเดือนอาจเดือน
พฤศจิกาก็ตัดเดือนธันวาก็ต้องตัดเดือน
มกราคมก็ต้องกลับแถวผ่าตัดไม่ได้ตัดเลย
ไม่ตัดเพราะว่าครูต้อง
ขี้เกียจไม่อยากตัดให้แล้วอยากให้เขาไป
ตัดที่ร้านจะได้หล่อๆกูต้องกลับแล้วสวย
ไหมคะหล่อไม่หรอ
ไม่อ่ะค่ะ
ลูกอ่ะลูกอ่ะลูกอ่ะโอเคลูกชอบมากหรอรูป
ชอบแต่แม่ไม่ชอบแต่แม่ไม่ชอบแม่อยากให้
ลูกดีกว่าหนีๆ
คะ
ก็ต้มทำยังไงล่ะคะลูกแม่ผมยาวแล้วโง่แม่
แม่แม่เอากรรไกรมาแม่ตัดผมให้หน่อยแม่แต่
กูไม่หน่อยไม่เอาไม่เอาได้ไม่ตัดไม่ตัด
ต่อไปไม่ตัดไม่ตัด
แม่ไม่ตัดนะลูกลูกเป็นผัดรูปภาพหอเซ็งเลย
เพราะเอาอิฐตังค์ให้ไปร้านตัดผมไปตัดที่
ร้าน
งั้นลูกก็บอกว่าไม่ไปจะให้แม่ตัดครั้งนี้
ครั้งที่ 2 ไปตัดที่ร้านไม่ไปจะให้แม่ตัด
2 ครั้ง 3 ครั้งแล้วตัดที่ร้านแพงไหมอ่ะ
อัดที่ร้านประมาณ
on  1  1 ครั้งค่ะ 1 ครั้ง
350 บาท 350 บาท
เลยค่ะ
อ๋อมีบางร้านก็ 500 บาท
ได้ค่ะ
แพงค่าจริงก็แพงนักเรียนไม่มี 50 บาทนะคะ
มีร้านตัดผมผู้ชาย 80 บาทน้อหัดเฉพาะผู้
ชายผู้ชายแต่แต่ว่าไม่สวยใช่ไหม 80 บาทก็
โอเคนะคะมันตัดผมแบบง่ายๆ
แล้วเอ่อให้เงินไปใช่ไหมเนี่ย 350 เขา
เมียมีสัตว์มีศาสตร์แล้วก็อาจปรับแล้วก็
ได้ไดร์แล้วก็บอก
กูต้องไปสระผมกับไดร์ผมน่ะเท่าไหร่คะ
ปฐมแล้วก็ไดร์ผม 5  150 บาทค่ะโอเคและก็
หน่อยๆค่ะชัดสระไดร์ตัดกรอบด้วย
350 บาทถึง 500 บาท 500 บาทให้ค่ะ
ได้เงินนี้มัน
ให้แล้ว
อากาศจากเขาก็จะเหนื่อยอ่ะเนาะว่าเขาต้อง
ยืนให้แล้วก็ตัดแล้วก็เองสวยหรือยังปวด
หลังปวดหลังปวดหลังปวดไหล่ค่ะอ้าๆค่ะ
ตอนก็เลยให้ตังค์ลูกชายไปตากลูกชายบอกไม่
ตัดน่ะอ่ะกูต้องคิดว่ากูต้อมต้องจูงมือไป
ตัดผมที่ร้านแล้วล่ะมีงานเพราะมันขี้
เกียจตัดใช่ไหมขี้เกียจมากเลยไม่อยากปาด
แล้วกูก้มอยากให้ลูกชายหล่อๆแต่คุณต้อง
ช่วงช่วงปิดน่ายางสามีเอ๋ค่ะ 3  EA เวลา
เวลาจะไปตัดผมนะเขาจะต้องมีโทรศัพท์แล้ว
ก็คณะจองเข้าจะต้องทนละโว้ยสวัสดีค่ะผม
ชื่อ
มิสเตอร์ที
อยากจะไปตัดผมพรุ่งนี้
ใช่ไหมสมมติวันนี้วันวันนี้วันที่ 8 ใช่
ไหมคะ R วันนี้วันที่ 8
พฤษภาคมจะคลิปตัดผมวันที่ 9
โทรศัพท์เราก็จองว่าจะไปลอง
พรุ่งนี้นะค่ะจะบอกว่าพรุ่งนี้วันที่ 9
เวลา
อ่ามันอ่ะ
13:00 น
13:00 นติดเอาต้องบอกชื่อใช่ไหมชื่อใช่
ค่ะชื่อมิสเวิล์ดอีอาร์
ขอ
ลบก่อนผมมิสเตอร์ที
สวัสดีครับต้องเป็นร้านทำผมฮัลโหลสวัสดี
ครับสวัสดีค่ะผมชื่อมิสเตอร์ทีครับอาคุณ
นทีพรุ่งนี้วันที่ 9
ผมคิดจะไปตัดผมตอน 13:00 นผมจะไปตัดผม
13:00 นขอจองครับอ่าขอจอยพรุ่งนี้วันที่
9  13:00 นไม่ว่างนะคะไม่มีช่างว่างเหรอ
ครับมีลูกค้าเต็มตลอดเลยค่ะเต็มเหรอครับ
โอเค
ว่างกี่โมงครับ
ว่างวันที่ 10 ค่ะวันที่ 10 วันที่ 10
13:00 นได้ไหมครับเมื่อ
วันที่ 10 บ่ายโมงโอเคค่ะโอเคครับวันที่
10 บ่ายโมงนะครับผมมิสเตอร์ทีนะครับ
เขาก็จะจองอ่ะที่ร้านร้านตัดผมก็จะบอกว่า
มาก่อนประมาณ 10 นาทีนะคะอ้าอาจจะไปต่อไป
ก็คือประมาณ 12:00 น
50 นะคะค่ะไม่ต้องไปเร็วๆตอนนี้โควิชอ่ะ
ไม่ต้องไปใช่
ก็ก็ต้องจองก่อนแล้วของต้องของต้อมแนว
ต้องโทรศัพท์จองให้ลูกชายด้วยค่ะเหมือน
กันเลยค่ะเหมือนกันเลยของครูต้อมก็ต้อง
โทรไปจองให้ลูกชายนะเขาก็พูดแบบคล้ายๆ
เหมือนๆกันแบบนี้เลยนะคะจะไปกูต้องโทร
ฮัลโหลจะไปพรุ่งนี้วันที่ 9 ได้ไหมคะเขา
บอกว่าหมอเขาบอกว่าไม่ได้ค่ะเต็ม
โอเคเต็มแล้วค่ะโอเควันที่ 10 ได้ไหมคะ
วันที่ 10 พอมาอีกทีนะคะจองวันนี้ด้วย
เหรอไม่ได้ค่ะโอ้ยให้โทรอีกทีค่ะของสามี
คู๋จองได้
จองได้กูต้องโทรไปวันที่ 10 อีกครั้ง
หนึ่งก็ไม่ว่างแล้ว
อ่ะกูต้องก็เลยจับมือไปเดินห้างเลยขอไม่
ต้องเจาะจงให้จองแล้วไปหาร้านมองหามองหา
มีร้านไหนได้อะไรเอาตอนนี้ได้แล้วเปิดและ
ได้แล้วมาย
กูต้องเข้าไปห้าง 1 ห้างในกรุงเทพฯได้
ห้าง 1 ห้างห้างเนี่ยนักเรียนค่าในประเทศ
ไทยก็จะมีห้างอะไรนะ
เอ็มโพเรียมมาก่อนค่าจ้าง
เซ็นทรัล-โรบินสันมอเตอร์ไซค์คา
ไม่ได้เป็นร้านที่ถนนไม่ได้ไปไปในหรือไป
ร้านไอค่ะ I ร้านที่อยู่ในห้าง Central
ก็โอเคมีข้างอ่ะข้างใหญ่ๆท้ายต้องกูเอ๋
รู้ไหมคะในร้านในห้างเนี่ยมีร้านทำผม
3 ล้าน 4 ล้านเยอะเลยนะคะขอให้ชื่ออะไร
อ่ะเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ริมชั่นบางนานี้เนี่ย
มีทั้งหมดกี่ชั้นคะห้างนะอ๋อคุณต้องคิด
ก่อนนะคะ 5 ชั้นค่ะ 1  2  3  3  4  4  5
มันอยู่ใต้ดินจอดรถโอเคอ่าใช่ๆๆนักเรียน F
E
ฮะ
โอเคก็มีชั้น B ใช่ไหมคะถ้าชั้น B2  1
ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3 ชั้น 4
นะคะชั้น 5 ของ
แล้วค่ะรักต้องชั้นไหนคะร้านตัดผมมีที่
ชั้น 3 หอฉันสามหนึ่งร้าน 5 ชั้น 4
ไม่อยู่ชั้นเดียวกันนะฉันสตรีมี 2 ล้าน
เขตอยู่ข้างๆกันฮ่าๆๆแล้ว R  R กูต้องคิด
ว่าพี่ชั้น 3 อะมีอีก 1 ล้านค่ะ 4 ล้าน
วิวต้องก็เดินเดินๆหาร้านมองหาร้านแล้วก็
เดินเดินๆทั้งสองคนกับลูกชายนะคะพี่อะคุณ
ต้อมกับลูกชาย
ถ้า
ไป 2 คนนะไป 2 คนเลยค่ะ
เดินหาร้านที่ 1 ร้านที่ไหนนะนี่
คนเต็มร้านเลยห่อมีคนคนมากๆ
โอเคเห็ดกับผมได้ไหมอยากได้แต่ไม่เอาเข้า
ไม่ได้คนเต็มคุณเยอะมากคิวยาวๆคนเยอะๆคน
นั่งรอนั่งรองเต็มเลยไม่เอาดีกว่าเนาะไม่
เอาดีกว่ามาเดินไปต่อที่ร้านที่ 2 ร้าน
ที่สองเป็นยังไงคะ
ร้านที่สองหมู่สูโขทัย
ค่ะค่ะเหม็นอะไร
ร้านนี้คนน้อยมีคนอยู่ 2 คนเองแต่ว่า
เหม็นมากเหม็นอิ่มพวกนี้ค่ะสเปรย์ที่ฉีด
ผมมาค่ะอ๋อเพราะว่าและสเปนเยอะไปหมดหมอ
แสดงว่าร้านนี้มีคนเซ็ตผมเยอะและมีให้ทำ
ผมไดร์ผมเซ็ตผมเกล้าผมก็ฉี่ฉีดฉีดฉีดฉีด
ฉีดเยอะมากเพราะมันก็เป็นเหมือนควันแบบ
นี้ใช่ไหมคะชายค่ะโอ้โอ๋ก็หมิงเอกไม่ชอบ
เลยเวลาน้องให้มันผมแล้วทางร้านเนี้ยสี
สีขาวเป็นเหมือนกับมีสีขาวลอยๆค่ะก็จะ
เหม็นมากนี้เหมือนแล้วก็แสบตาค่ะ 5 ต้อม
ก็เลยหาไม่เข้าไม่เข้าไม่เอาครูต้อมก็
เดินเดินเดินไปอีกไปไปชั้นไหนคะไปชั้น 4
ค่ะให้ชั้น 4 ร้านที่ 3 หรือเปล่าคะไป
ร้านที่ 3 ค่ะร้านที่ 3 ก็
เงียบสนิทถ้ามีคนไม่มีคนไม่มีสเปรย์ไม่
เหม็นไม่มีสเปรย์แต่งไม่เหม็นแต่กูต้อง
ไม่เอาทำไมเดี๋ยวคุณต้องร้านชื่อหนึ่งอ่ะ
เปิดคุยตื่นเต้นร้านที่ 1 คนเยอะไม่เอา
ร้านที่สองเมสะเปโอก็คนโอเคใช่มั้ย 1
ทรายเหม็นไม่เอาเหล้าดีมากไม่มีคน
ไม่มีคนเลยกูต้องก็เลยคิดว่าร้านเนี้ย
ราคา
แฮนด์
หรือคิดว่าร้านเนี้ยทำผมไม่ดีไม่สวยอาจ
ไม่ดี
ก็เลยไม่ออกเลยไม่เอา
ไม่พูดต้องก็เข้าไปแล้วถามได้ถามว่าขอโทษ
นะคะตัดผม 1 ครั้งเท่าไหร่
อาจเดี๋ยวป้องก็ได้กูต้องไม่ถามกูต้องลอง
เดินเดินเดินไปก่อนแล้วบังเอิญตาไปเห็น
ร้านที่ปี่อ๋ออ๋อร้านนี้ร้านที่ 4
ร้านด้วยเพลงคนไหมค่ะร้านที่ 4 มีคนโอเค
อ่อนนิดหน่อยสิฮะนิดหน่อยโอเคแล้วก็ช่าง
ทำผมช่างทำผมก็แบบคึกคักคึกคัก
จุ๊บๆๆๆหูดูเก่งมากสนุกมั้ยสนุกดูตื่น
เต้นสนุกสนานมากร้านนี้ดูวัยรุ่นจะสับไป
กดต้องไปตัดผมหรือไปเที่ยว
ป้อมก็ดูร้านที่มันคึกคักหน่อยค่ะอ๋อก็
ได้ด่าที่ 4 นะคะให้ร้านที่ 4 ท่านี้บอก
ลูกชายว่าลูกร้านนี้โอเคแม่นะแม่คิดว่า
โอเคปัดดีใครตัดผมคะเนี่ย
ลูกค่ะฉันวุฒิยังไม่ถามลูกเหรอลูกจะไป
ร้านที่ 300 ล้านที่ 4 ห้ามคาถามถามเขา
ว่ารักนี่โอเคไหมงูเขาก็คือฮู้ไม่โอเคอ่า
นะว่าไงนี่แม่ก็ไม่โอเค
คิดเหมือนกันนะลูกนี่ค่ะตกลงได้ร้านที่ 4
ร้านที่ 4 ลูกก็เข้าไปตัดผมเข้าไปอ่าช่าง
ก็ถามว่าทำอะไรคะ
ก็บอกช่างว่าตัดผมค่ะคนเดียวเพราะว่ากู
ต้องไป 2 คนใช่ไหมคะเขาบอกช่างว่าอาจผมคน
เดียวทรงอะไรให้ยังไม่ได้บอกเลยค่ะกูต้อง
ไม่ได้บอกลูกชายก็ไม่ได้พูดไม่ได้บอกเลย
เค้าถามมั้ยเขาไม่ถามค่ะว่าหรอเขาถามแค่
ว่าถ้าคืออะไรอ่ะทำอะไรก็เชิญค่ะแล้วก็
เอาลูกชายไปสระผมก่อนสระผมเสร็จก็ออกมา
นั่งที่เก้าอี้กับผมค่ะกูต้องก็ไม่ได้บอก
ไม่ได้พูดอะไรนั่งรอนั่งรอนั่งรอไปแล้วก็
หนูเวลาดูลูกออกกำลังตัดอยู่รูปกำลังตัด
อยู่โอเคต้มก็เลยรู้ไปหลายตังค์จ่ายตังค์
ที่เคาน์เตอร์
โอเค
350 บาทนะคะแล้วก็นั่งรอลูกอีกแป๊บนึง
อ่ะตัดผมเสร็จกูหล่อมากเลยกูต้อมก็ถามลูก
ว่าบอกกับช่างทำผมไหมว่าจะตัดแบบไหนค่ะ
ลูกบอกว่าไม่ได้บอก
คิดว่าแม่บอกกับช่างว่าให้ตัดแบบนี้
เขาไม่ได้บอกแต่พี่ก็ไม่ได้บอกแม่คือต้อง
ไม่ได้บอกลูกไม่ได้บอกช่าง
ช่างคิดเองแล้วพูดกับลูกว่าลงหนูเล็กใช่
ไหมนะก็ตัดเลยมูเลทมันส่งอะไรนะกูเอกก็
ไม่รู้เรื่องเลิศมูเลทเป็นทรงวัยรุ่นชอบ
ค่ะข้างหน้าจะสั้นๆหน่อยทั้งหลังจะยาวๆ
หน่อยอ่าเป็นทรงผู้ชายวัยรุ่นค่ะคือทรง
มูเลทอาปรากฏว่าลูกอ่ะชอบมากถูกใจมากแล้ว
ก็คิดว่าแม่เป็นคนบอกกับช่างอ๋อฉันผู้
หญิงหรือผู้ชายผู้ชายค่ะโอ้ช่างเก่งมาก
ช่างหยุดคิดแล้วก็รู้ใจรู้ใจวัยรุ่นมาก
อ๋อ
โอเคตอนนี้ครูต้องกับลูกชายก็ชอบ
รายการที่ 4 เลยใช่ไหมชอบมากเลยร้านนี้
แล้วก็โหถูกใจตัดผมแบบหล่อมาก
ค่ะที่บ้าน 3
เดี๋ยวเดี๋ยว
สามีไม่ชอบผมวัยรุ่นคิดว่าเวลาปรับผม
เนี่ยก็จะต้องมีว่าร้านวัยรุ่นร้านใหญ่
ร้านห้อยผู้หญิงร้านของผู้ชายได้แล้วก็จะ
เกิดผู้ชายที่เป็นผู้ใหญ่บางคนไปร้านวัย
รุ่นตัดมันอะไรน่ะชอบก็ไม่ชอบ
งั้นลูกชายก็ได้ร้านตัดผมที่ชอบแล้วใช่
ไหมคะพี่ชอบค่ะแล้วผู้ใบรุ่นก็ดีใจด้วย
ค่ะเรียนคะอ่ะนักเรียนจะไม่เห็นรูปลูกชาย
คุณต้อมนะคะลูกงานนะผู้ต้องถ่ายถ่ายรูป
ข้างหลังของลูกชายให้ครูอินทร์ก็เพราะว่า
ลูกชายกูต้องอายใช่ไหมไม่ชอบให้คนเห็น
หน้านะคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เบาะครูเอเอารูปให้ดูไม่ได้นะคะไม่ได้ขอ
ขอบคุณนะคะครูต้อมวันนี้มาคุยเล่าเรื่อง
ร้านตัดผมนะคะก็อย่างนึงกูอยากรู้ไปหน้า
ตัดผมต้องใส่หน้ากากอนามัยไหมใส่ถ้าเขา
ยังต้องติดนะคะยังต้องใส่แม้สู่ค่ะคู๋คะ
แล้วเวลาที่เรานอนปากผมก็ต้องใส่นะคะช่าง
ก็ต้องใส่เราจะใส่เราก็สั่งเอาว่าตรง Mass
เนี่ยตรงหูว่าค่ะเวลารักษามันก็จะเปียกนะ
คะนอกก็ต้องเอาไปเปลี่ยนเอาแม้เปลี่ยน 2
อันก็ได้หัวค่ะ
ก็กูเองไม่ได้เข้างานกับผงตัดผมข้ามปีตัด
ยังไงกูเอกก็ยังไงอ่ะ
มีอีกที่กหรือแบบนี้ผมก็น่ารักดีแล้วค่ะ
เพื่อเนี่ยเพื่อนตับให้น่ารักค่ะเป็นต่อ
ภัยแล้วรออยู่ไขค่าโอเควันนี้เราหมดเวลา
แล้วนะคะเอ๋เลยแล้ววันนี้เราไปก่อนนะคะ
เพลงขอบคุณนะคะพี่เอกสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบายน